living in hype house isn't all fun and
games and Charlie and Dixie's Emilio can
attest to that there are plenty of
strict rules tic toc errs have to follow
if they want to continue living in the
la-based mansion context Raiders have
already been kicked out for
disrespecting the rolls but more on that
later watch until the very end to find
out which rule forbids tick stalkers
from going out on the weekends
collaborative house where people can
come over and feel comfortable making
content here instead of like a frat
house le locals were skeptical when news
of hype house first made headlines
ever since YouTube's Jake Paul created
the content collective team 10 locals
have tried their best to prevent
teenagers from running mansions in their
neighboring communities but hype house
creators little hoodie and Thomas Petro
have reassured locals that hype house is
nothing like team 10 first of all there
are rules when it comes to pranks
parties and loud festivities as a whole
first and foremost type house is a place
for creativity productivity and content
creation so house parties and huge
gatherings are simply against the rules
partying is just not what hype house is
about lil hoodie and Thomas have clearly
done their homework they don't plan on
repeating any of Jake Paul's mistakes
and they definitely don't plan on having
lawsuits filed against them according to
the New York Times Thomas told future
collaborators that if they want to party
there are hundreds of houses that throw
parties in LA every weekend they want to
report yes this is a family it's like
it's actually a really good environment
sure Charlie and Dixie are extremely
famous but their parents mark and Heidi
still want what's best for them and they
aren't ready to part ways with their
girls just yet although some of the hype
House members do live in the mansion
full-time this isn't the case for
Charlie and Dixie
both sisters are still in high school
and completing their education is of the
utmost importance so the girls still
live at home with their parents but
during an interview with the New York
Times the girls did state that they
spend as much time at hype house as they
can mark and Heidi who are almost famous
tick tock stars have a set of rules they
want their daughters to follow but they
don't want to infringe on their creative
freedom during the same interview mark D
Emilio revealed that as parents one
thing they say all the time is that this
is just about creating options for their
kids mark also admitted that while he
doesn't know where this whole hype house
thing is going he hopes that his
daughters can do what they love and most
importantly be happy as long as their
girls sleep at home at night and go to
school in the morning the D'Amelio
are happy my family's my support system
I know that they all have my back
Charlie D Emilio might be hype houses
youngest tick tock star but she's also
the tick talker with the most followers
the 15 year old has over 34 million
followers on the platform whereas her 18
year old sister Dixie has about 14
million the sisters are pros when it
comes to producing daily videos and
that's a good thing considering that
hype House members are obliged to
turnout daily content if House members
fail to respect this role they can get
kicked out of hype house in the blink of
an eye charlie is famous for her
lip-syncing and choreographed dance
videos and Dixie is well known for her
similar dance style and comedic videos
the girls don't seem to have any issues
juggling their schoolwork and content
creation duties so they're in the clear
for now but wait what happens when a
House member fails to upload daily
content
well according to Thomas if someone
slips up constantly they won't be a part
of the team anymore
Thomas also stated that tick talkers
can't come and stay with them for a week
and not make any videos so we want to be
putting out a couple videos a week of
groups
tik-tok is especially popular with
people under 18 years old so when
creating hype house chase Hudson aka lil
hoodie and Thomas knew that they had to
stay on trend with her brand to hold on
to their popularity chase Thomas and the
creator collective hype house are signed
with WME and to remain in good standing
with WME they have to uphold the hype
house's stellar reputation getting into
trouble with the cops or giving hype
house a bad reputation can put them in
hot waters with the agency so their
brand is their bond it doesn't matter
how many followers a person has certain
rules need to be followed especially
since the agency has contracts with
minors that's why the party culture is
so frowned upon at hype house thomas
revealed that partying is not in line
with anyone in the houses brand the D
Emilio sisters have to be on their best
behavior to prevent fans from boycotting
them can you imagine what would happen
if a bunch of teenagers moved in to hide
house without having a set of golden
rules to follow yeah it would be anarchy
luckily everything has been carefully
planned to protect the collaborators
rights while maintaining a friendly and
productive atmosphere unlike Jake Paul's
team 10 the members of hype house aren't
made to allocate a portion of their
earnings to a head honcho
however they are expected to replace
something if they break or damage it for
the most part the hype house residents
aren't nearly as destructive as team 10
so maintaining the mansion's current
state hasn't been a problem Jake Paul
was sued for two million dollars for
trashing the team ten house so just in
case history repeats itself hype how has
added a you break you buy role to their
contract if someone breaks something
they have a total of 15 days to replace
it you know we argue we fight we have
our differences but the end of the day
we all go to bed we still love each
other
Thomas was inspired to create hype house
after spending time in the team 10
mansion he quickly realized that having
popular tick stalkers in one place could
boost views in a matter of seconds so we
got to work recruiting some of the
biggest tick tock errs on the platform
Thomas and chase decided to run out a
huge LA mansion with 20 other tick tock
errs which made running a room very
affordable most of the House members do
not live in the mansion full-time but
they run a room for about $900 a month
they're free to come and go as they
please as long as they create daily
content while ensuring to be present on
collab days collab days are super
important for hype House members
appearing in each other's videos and
creating new content for the hype house
tick tock page helps everyone involved
get more followers and views members are
expected to promote each other creating
organic growth in the process Thomas
told Forbes that Charlie Dee Emilio
changed the tick tock app by uploading
dance videos with her help everyone at
hype house is creating new and fun
dances that bring in loads of traffic
we're just trying to push each other as
best we can when you're on the outside
looking in
hi pops can come off as a place where
teens go to throw blowout parties but
that's the opposite of what hype house
is about when you're on the inside
looking out it's clear that the mansion
is a place of business where like-minded
people go to create content for their
slew of fans where as Charlie and
Dixie's parents are free to come and go
as they please the girls still need to
get permission before inviting some of
their friends over high-pass creators
and investors want to make sure that the
group members are respecting the rules
and they also want to ensure that their
stars are well protected
so the gated community only opens for
visitors who have been approved ahead of
time tons of new faces head to hype
house on collab days but these visitors
are there to have fun and be themselves
while creating tick tock videos if Dixie
and Charlie want to hang out with their
friends they're better off doing it at
home
a little way I am when cheese Hudson
decided to create hype house he
immediately contacted the D Emilio
sisters because their brand was so on
point these two social media stars got
to where they are today by being
themselves they're all about embracing
their inner weirdness and connecting
with fans through relatable content so
when chase approaches new collaborators
he keeps authenticity in mind he wants
everyone at the hype house to bring
something new to the table and as long
as they're respectful and have plenty of
followers pretty much anything goes
chases the group scout and according to
Cosmopolitan he's looking for people who
are talented weird funny or extremely
good-looking
luckily for Charlie and Dixie they check
all of these boxes hype House members
could potentially lose their spot if
they stopped being true to themselves
and mislead their fans viewers want
original content so copying others just
isn't an option keep posting keep going
you're gonna you're gonna do big things
in life you just can't focus on what
they have to say the tic-tock world is
super competitive but typically accounts
that have the most followers get the
most views the members of hype house are
scared to get comfortable and lose
stamina they want their follower base to
keep growing every single day so to grow
their accounts pipe House members
collaborate with different tick talkers
every single week and so far charlie has
managed to bring in around 200,000 new
followers every single day everyone at
hype house is encouraged to attend
tik-tok events where they can connect
with their fans while inspiring new ones
to follow them attending huge events
like YouTube's VidCon party is a must
fans will be lining up to meet Charlie
and Dixie as well as other members of
the hype house at the 2020 VidCon event
take the bullying back fingers across
I'm self-conscious
we already know that hype house isn't a
party house but did you know that
partying is against the rules in general
sure tick talkers are allowed to go out
and party if that's what they really
want but they're expected to be ready to
film bright and early on Saturday and
Sunday mornings since many of the hype
House members go to school during the
week the majority of the group's videos
are filmed on the weekend Thomas told
the New York Times that hype house is
about creating something big and you
can't do that if you're going out on the
weekends House members are expected to
be fresh-faced and healthy on Saturday
and Sunday mornings being hungover and
unwilling to shoot videos can result in
a tick talker being kicked out of high
faust and that's a wrap on the ten
strict rules Charlie and Dixie have to
follow would you have trouble respecting
these rules if you lived in hype house
tell us in the comments just like these
people have your back thanks for
watching for more great content be sure
to LIKE this video and subscribe to the
things we'll see you again soon
[Music]